hello again uh everybody now the
government's introduced a new police
task force to help protect young women
and children from abuse let's get the
view from labor should we standing by
for is this the shadow Home Secretary
Yvette Cooper hello Miss Cooper thanks
for joining us always a pleasure to see
you
um we've been here and the Home
Secretary of your counterparts over the
weekend uh blaming senior labor
politicians for uh failed action on
grooming gangs when you guys were in
power uh what would you say in response
I think sadly we have a conservative
Home Secretary who always looks for
other people to blame but herself or but
the government that's in power the
measures that the ministers seem to be
announcing today on Specialists police
um support and also on reporting of
child abuse are ones that labor was
calling for 10 years ago and the
government repeatedly refused to
introduce them and refused to act if
they were serious about tackling child
sexual abuse and exploitation where is
the strategy on tackling the online
grooming and abuse that is escalating
and accelerating fast where is their
response to the full report of the
independent inquiry into child sexual
exploitation and abuse which looked at
exploitation by organized gangs but also
looked at institutional abuse including
in church and religious organizations
and in Care Homes and where is the
action to speed up court cases which are
currently taking years over the last
seven years while the conservatives have
been in power the number of prosecutions
and convictions for child sexual abuse
has plummeted that is a devastating
record and it's the conservatives record
well uh the Home Secretary said that you
guys failed to act when you could when
you're in power because of in her words
cultural sensitivities and political
correctness out of fear of being called
racist
yeah but once again I think this is just
suel abrahman looking for other people
to blame so the Louise Casey report in
2015 uh identified problems around
Rotherham and around cultural
sensitivities preventing investigations
into child sexual exploitation at that
time and we've always been really clear
that ethnicity racism or cultural
sensitivities can never be an excuse for
failing to go after the perpetrators of
child sexual exploitation however that
was eight years ago and the government
failed to introduce any of the measures
that we and others called for eight
years ago to tackle child sexual
exploitation to go after grooming gangs
to take the measures that were needed so
unfortunately we have a Home Secretary
and a prime minister who have been doing
nothing the year after year after year
and all they've got now is some rhetoric
all they've got now is some measures
that we called four years ago and
they're still not addressing the much
broader issues around child sexual abuse
and exploitation that are serious
problems today
uh Shadow Home Secretary though my
viewers this morning will want to know
if there is something in this claim
whether you were in power whether the
conservatives are in power whether you
will be in power again come the next
election whenever that might be where
there were two politically correct
um as the government suggests to take on
these grooming gangs
so that was something that Louise Casey
in her review Louise Casey did a
previous review to the one that we're
normally talking about she did a review
back in 2015 into Rotherham Council and
what happened then and that was exactly
what she found and that is why we called
and many other people called for much
stronger measures at that time because
you cannot ever allow any kind of
sensitivities around racial ethnicity to
ever prevent action around child sexual
exploitation and abuse so you have to
take that action but equally you also
have to look at the child sexual
exploitation and abuse wherever it is
coming from and what the nspcc have said
is look you can't be narrow about this
because you'll just create new blind
spots you have to look at it wherever it
is so that just goes back to my son some
of these points were made eight years
ago and the government failed to act
they should have acted then it's no good
to just have partial action there well
you need to have action on all kinds of
abuse including for example the findings
that the inquiry found in in the
Anglican church or the Catholic church
or in Care Homes across the country they
set out serious proposals for reform
around child protection and around the
response from institutions and around
the additional safeguarding that's in
place where's the government's response
to any of those issues so we have to
deal with some of those things that
happened in Rotherham they should have
been dealt with eight years ago and
that's why we called for mandatory
reporting and for the the stronger
police specialist policing at that time
but you also have to deal with different
forms of abuse wherever it is whatever
Community it's in whatever the
background of perpetrating whatever the
background of the victim we only have a
finite amount of time thank you for
sparing the time this morning
um what do you blame for what happened
in Dover over the weekend when some kids
were in a coach for up to 20 hours not
able to get across the channel
oh it's a total nightmare for those
children you had school trips being
canceled but they would have been
looking forward to and then just you
know canceled as a result of all of this
chaos look clearly there are additional
passport checks and things as a result
of brexit that's obviously factually the
case but our approach has been to say we
need to make brexit work and that means
doing proper planning and having proper
systems in place and it is it's just
incomprehensible that the Home Secretary
the transport secretary failed to work
with the port of Dover with the French
authorities to have proper planning in
place for Coach parties because that's
what it comes down to is the
arrangements for Coach parties they
ought to be able to get a grip and work
together but we need some leadership
again from the Home Secretary rather
than her just blaming everyone else
which sadly is something that the
conservative ministers keep doing
okay
um final thought apparently stevenage
woman is who you are aiming at in your
campaign ahead of the next general
election socially conservative
previously voted Tory could hold a key
to your victory at the next election I'm
old enough to remember Mondeo man I
think it's fair to say that you probably
are as well who do you think will
identify as stevenage woman
I don't know I've got lots of friends in
stevenage actually and um I think we
will be putting boats right across the
country
um whether it's in uh stevenage or
Worcester or working through all the
other places that people always focus on
uh whatever kinds of cars they drive as
well I think you're right we've got the
local elections coming up after 13 years
it to me it feels like so many services
are broken that's why Labor's
campaigning is a much better alternative
we're out of time always great to see
you and enjoy the break over Easter
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thank you